also mein Thema heute Abend ist unsere
Wirtschaft denn die blutet aus
deutschland droht eine Abwanderung
wichtiger Industrie nach Nordamerika wie
das Handelsblatt berichtet hat und es
droht eine Destabilisierung der
Wirtschaft schon jetzt haben die
Unternehmer Angst vor der
Energieversorgung im nächsten Jahr wie
viel nach acht exklusiv erfuhr herrscht
bereits jetzt eine Gas und
strommangelage und sie trifft unsere
mittelständischen Unternehmen die bei
den großen Anbietern wie Eon keine
Energiemengen mehr für das Jahr 2023
einkaufen können also wir rufen da an
und können dann für das Jahr 2023 keine
Energiemenge abschließen während
Haushalte und kleinere Betriebe
automatischen Ersatzversorgung fallen
während der industrielle Mittelstand
also jetzt bei Stadtwerken und
heimischen Grundversorgern um das Gas
betteln muss denn große Konzerne
individuell beurteilt müssen sich
schlimmstenfalls nur auf Reduzierungen
einstellen das wirtschaftliche Rückgrat
unserer Gesellschaft wird in meinen
Augen so vernichtet wenn dort es nicht
schnell hilft und Änderungen gibt wir
haben ja hier heute auch einen
Familienunternehmer am Tisch sitzen die
Nachfolge ist bei auch schon geregelt
Herr grob und meine Frage ist natürlich
wie sieht es mit ihrer Stromversorgung
im nächsten Jahr aus beliefern Sie noch
die großen Energieversorger wie E.ON und
Co wir haben ja Kunde Energie Gas und
machen mit zwei Gasturbinen in der
Stunde 1600 Kubik machen wir selber
eigene eigenen Eigenstrom und brauchen
entsprechend das Gas 2020 vor zwei
Jahren haben wir etwa 100.000 Euro im
Monat Gaskosten gehabt letztes Jahr 2021
hat sich's verdoppelt auf 200.000 und
jetzt ist so ein bisschen gesunken aber
wo auf dem Höchststand war wer hätten
wir pro Monat eine Million Gaskosten
gehabt das heißt 12 Millionen jetzt
liegen sie bei jetzt zu so etwa bei 9
Millionen das ist für uns natürlich
nicht machbar ich wir haben 100%
Eigenkapital wir haben stille Reserven
das kann ich auch eine gewisse Zeit
durchhalten selbstverständlich aber ich
sag mal das ist nicht um kalkulierbar in
unsere Produkte weil wir auch ein
Produkt haben das niemand mehr braucht
denn wer bei uns Qualität kauft kann
sich leisten und hat normal den Schrank
voll und dann gefällt ihm die Ware oder
die Qualität und die leistet er sich
aber wenn er knapp bei Kasse wird dann
ist aus dann wird unser Produkt als
erstes gespart auch ich werde mir keinen
neuen Anzug anfertigen lassen weil ich
habe genügend ich mache es nur wenn es
mir leisten kann und so warten wir drauf
im Moment ist die Nachfrage noch sehr
gut aber ich warte drauf bis natürlich
der Winter mal Fuß gefasst hat und die
Probleme von denen wir sprechen die
Energiepreise können sie sich leisten
als Trigema wir können Sie aus den
Reserven bezahlen wir die aber ich kann
das nicht Jahre durchhalten das ist
nicht da weil ich sag mal dann müsste
ich die Produkte 20 30 Prozent oder 40
Prozent die Preise anheben und das ist
nicht machbar
so bleibt durchhalten können also ich
habe ich selbstverständlich meinen
Mitarbeitern die Arbeitsplätze auch in
der pandem in den pandemiejahren sofort
immer garantiert und da gibt es
hergestellt im ersten Jahr im zweiten
Jahr haben wir online war wesentlich
stärker haben wir 50 Prozent der das was
unsere Geschäfte nicht verkaufen konnten
weil sie geschlossen waren auf Lager
gearbeitet und das finanzieren wir
natürlich auch und sind dann vielleicht
später froh dass wir in das Lager haben
so wie wir jetzt auf froh sind dass wir
große Rohstofflager und gefärbte Stoffe
am Lager haben und im Zweifelsfall
natürlich unsere Näherin auch
beschäftigen können wenn wir Stoff
weniger färben weil wir im Prinzip
weniger Gas kriegen wir bezahlen im
Moment das Gas aber wenn es weniger wird
und wenn man gar keins mehr bekommt dann
müsste ich die Stoffherstellung das
heißt dann kann ich auch wenn ich kein
Strom mehr machen kann ich brauche ja
ein Jahr etwa um wenn ich sage auf Öl
umstellen dann habe ich eine haben wir
Ölkessel bestellt sofort aber der da hat
ein Jahr Lieferzeit das heißt auch für
die ganze technische Umstellung brauche
ich ein Jahr und so lange brauche ich
auf jeden Fall Gas um die Beschäftigung
zusammenzufassen bevor wir Jan Schäfer
Fragen es ist kritisch für Trigema auch
die Situation wir hatten viele
kritischen Zeiten wir hatten natürlich
es ist kritisch natürlich es ist
unangenehm und ich sag mal natürlich
kostet uns das Geld aber wir haben ja
auch wir dadurch dass wir auch nie ein
Jahr mit Verlusten abgeschlossen haben
haben wir ja Reserven und werden das
auch durchhalten die Mitarbeiter
brauchen keine Angst haben ich
beschäftige sie auch in dieser
schwierigen Zeit weil das ist mein
Problem und nicht das Mitarbeiter das
mitarbeiterproblem die müssen ihre
Leistung bringen und ich muss meine
Leistung bringen indem ich Probleme löse
und wir werden alles tun aber in der
Hoffnung dass irgendwann natürlich die
Politik einsieht dass das so nicht
weitergehen kann aber jetzt kommt
natürlich meine entscheidende Frage wie
kann es überhaupt dazu kommen wie kommt
es dazu dass man 40 Jahren top
zusammenarbeitet sich 100% abhängig
macht von Russland oder von Putin und
von heute auf morgen ist man tot sein da
muss etwas passiert sein was ich sage
das hätten die Politiker spüren müssen
und wir hätten das auf jeden Fall die
problematisch lösen müssen wenn ich von
meinem Geschäft rüber gehe gegenüber
wohne ich und da würden sich zwei
streiten oder Schlägern und ich würde
nach Hause gehen und dem einen eine
große Axt bringen und dem anderen ein
großes Messer dann würden sie
selbstverständlich sagen der grob hat
nicht mehr alle Tassen im Schrank der
muss doch die auseinander dividieren der
muss die besänftigen und nicht sie mit
sozusagen mit Axt und und wir fragen mal
den politik-chef der Bild wieder
Vergleich funktioniert von Herr Group
der Vergleich den auf den würde ich
gerne gleich gerne einmal kurz zu
sprechen kommen ich fand aber spannend
was Sie gesagt haben wir Gruppe und hat
mir gerade vorgestellt wenn ich jetzt
Robert habe wäre was gewissermaßen
vielleicht für Belustigung hier am Tisch
sorgen kann dann hätte ich mich zum
einen gefreut über das was sie gesagt
haben nämlich dass sie die Arbeitsplätze
ihrer Mitarbeiter nicht nur in der
corona-krise aber auch jetzt wieder
gesichert haben aber ich hätte
wahrscheinlich erschrocken auf den
Fernsehschirmen oder hier am Tisch auf
mit der Faust auf den Tisch gehauen bei
der Aussage von ihnen dass sie jetzt
möglicherweise bei Gas rausholen aber
sich stattdessen Ölkessel bestellt haben
und dann künftig nicht mehr mit Gas aber
mit Öl ihre Energie betreiben wollen
Ihre Firma betreiben wollen deswegen
auch die ernstgemeinte Frage ist das für
sie die einzige Alternative gewesen oder
gab es nicht die Möglichkeit zu sagen
wir machen das jetzt regenerativ
beispielsweise mit Sonne oder mit Wind
das Problem ist natürlich haben wir
alles diskutiert wir haben ja sofort
eine Firma engagiert die uns alles
durchsucht und sagt was ist machbar und
das erste ist machbar dass wir Öl
besorgen und mit Öl etwas ein Kessel
haben und den Kessel besorgen dass wir
sagen dass wir also wenn man es Gas ganz
gestoppt ist dass wir mit Öl heizen
können dann gibt es natürlich auch
Wasserstoff das würde aber drei Jahre
dauern bis wir umgestellt haben und wenn
sie sagen Solar ja die Mengen der die
diesen wir haben Solar Dächer aber wir
haben alles was machbar war was
vernünftig war wo der Sonneneinstrahlung
entsprechend war auf unserem
firmendächern haben wir mit Solar
ausgestattet aber man hat mir gesagt das
ist ein oder zwei Prozent des
Strombedarfs kann ich damit machen also
sie müssen feststellen sehen dass wir
700 Näherinnen haben 700 Nähmaschinen
Strickmaschinen verbreit die riesen
riesen Heißwasser brauchen und
aufgeheizt werden muss also wir brauchen
1600 kW in der Stunde das sind ein
Beispiel von vielen Unternehmer in
diesem Land ich habe ja auch am Anfang
dieses Beispiel gebracht Herr Brüderle
was mich wirklich schockiert hat das
mittelständische Unternehmen jetzt
gesagt bekommt von Eon also ab 1 Januar
2023 können wir keinen Strom also kein
Gas mehr verkaufen wie schlimm ist denn
die Lage für den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland können natürlich zu anderen
Grundversorgern gehen wenn ihr den
Stadtwerken also die haben jetzt nicht
alle ab 1 Januar keinen Strom mehr kein
Gas mehr aber wie schwierig ist die Lage
von Industriestandort Deutschland ist
extrem schwierig das Ergebnis einer
verfielten Energiepolitik jetzt auf die
Füße fällt war natürlich schön bequem
will ich es russisches Gas zu nehmen das
lange Zeit ja günstig war übrigens auch
die Begründung des jetzt nostrain 2 die
Leitung beschädigt ist da kommt ja gar
nichts mehr durch das so die Versorgung
gar nicht berühren bei uns
die EOS können auch nur das verkaufen
was sie haben die Stadtwerke selbst
produzieren ja kein Gas hier kaufen es
bei E.ON oder andere Händler uniper um
es dann weiter zu geben sie haben mir
gerade eine eigene Produktion dabei ist
nur Verteilung die dort erfolgen und die
Situation hat sich über Nacht verändert
wir dürfen einfach nicht mehr also die
Unternehmer
betrug wenn E.ON gasverkäufer also gar
nicht haben ist sehr betrug die können
das nur verkaufen was sie auch verfügbar
haben die Mengen sind nicht da bekommst
nicht 55% war russisches Gas weg 0 und
es war auch eine fahrlässige Politik ich
habe das ja auch eine erlebt auch zum
Teil noch einen amtsfunktion damals war
der Gedanke weil wir hatten ja die
Kernkraftwerke um 10 Jahr verlängert die
CDU fdp-koalition ich habe daraus fährt
und dann ist in Japan 12.000 Kilometer
entfernt der Unfall passiert ja das war
Taifun und was alles zusammen ist
Erdbeben und auch in der Anlage etwas
und das hat über Nacht dazu geführt das
war eine denkwürdige Nacht wo Frau
Merkel
und auch der bayerische
Ministerpräsident entschieden haben
Seehofer wir gehen zurück auf die zehn
Jahre die rot-grün-beschlossen aber
hätten sie nichts dagegen tun können
damals
gehabt über die Regierung zu entscheiden
wir haben ja ein demokratisches System
wo Mehrheiten sind und Parteiführer
natürlich ein Preh haben ich habe das
nächsten Morgen deutscher vorgehört als
ich das Präsidium gefahren ist und
Gedanke war dort auch von der grünen
leibhaft begrüßt dass das was wegfällt
ich kenne Energie und Kohle wohl
baumöglich schnell raus durch Gas
ersetzt wird zwar bewusst die Strategie
durch rosige Gas die Lücke die durch
schnelleren Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie
und durch Ausstieg aus der Kohle
entstanden ist auszugleichen und das war
das Risiko mit 55 Prozent was
reingekommen ist und ich war immer der
Auffassung soll erst aus der Kohle
rausgehen weil die viel umsehen
schädlicher ist als die Kernenergie die
ganze Welt nutzt Energie sie brauchen
neue nur in Deutschland hat damals die
politische Stimmung die Entscheidung
auch der dreier-koalition der Skizze so
als Partei dazu rechne wir gehen raus
und es war gerade zu Euphorie die haben
sie überschlagen dabei wie schnell bei
der ausgehen soll damit ist diese
Gefälle Lage entstanden jetzt wundern
sich dass sie diese Strategie
eingeschlagen haben Russland an der
andere Strategie gefahren ist und die
haben ja diplomatisch versucht die Minsk
Gespräche noch mal die Format waren ja
alles diplomatisch Versuch gescheitert
sind das hat nicht funktioniert und
Russland nicht nur putin ist ja nicht
ein Mann der alles bestimmt ist auch
eine ganze Herrscher Clique die dort
Entscheidungen trifft hat sich
entschieden womit man nicht gerechnet
hatte Ukraine einzumarschieren wird man
nicht gedacht ist es noch gibt in
unseren Zeiten des einen Land vom
anderen überfallen wird die einfach
einmarschieren und sagen wir wollen es
haben das kann souveränes Land mehr das
gehört Russland wem auch immer aber
jedenfalls nicht eigenständig daraus die
Situation entstanden da muss sie noch
die Sanktionen entstand auf EU-Ebene
dass man auch gar keinen Bezug mehr
haben wollte damit ist dann
Schlussstrich da kann man darüber
streiten das war billig war schön aber
die Zeit nehmen einmal festhalten dass
daran jetzt nicht nur Putin Russland
schuldet sondern auch die falsche
deutsche Politik an der Misere die wir
gerade haben die einseitige Ausrichtung
mit 55% von einem lieferantenabhängig zu
sein mit der Group wahrscheinlich nie
machen würde man sagen irgendwie dass es
einfach etwas was nicht geht mich
faszinierender dieser gesamten
Debatte das irgendwie alle immer jetzt
erzählen wie das alles so gekommen ist
und jetzt sind alle irgendwie überrascht
und niemand wird haftbar gemacht für gar
nichts die die deutsche Wirtschaft geht
gerade den Bach runter und irgendwie
will niemand jetzt wirklich die
Verantwortung dafür übernehmen auch
nicht diejenigen die über zehn Jahre
dafür gesorgt haben dass wir in diese
Abhängigkeit hineingeraten sind weil es
ist natürlich nicht Putin Schuld und es
ist auch nicht die Ukraine schuld dass
wir uns mit 55 Prozent an Russland
gebunden haben sondern das war ja eine
freiwillige Entscheidung die man aber
nicht abgesichert hat und ich frage mich
langsam wirklich was eigentlich in
diesen Ministerien hauptberuflich
gemacht wird so ganz einfach ist es
nicht also es sind schon Leute die was
machen dabei aber es war eine politische
Entscheidung war man glaubte dass
gemeinsam europäische Haus den etwa die
Rede vom Putin von Dr Bundestag
zu gewinnen also es war doch eigentlich
schon eine Entscheidung die Bürger
wollten es ja und dann ist ja die
Politik umgeschwenkt oder ist Wettbewerb
der Parteien um Zustimmung des
Demokratie so funktioniert sie ist
anders Betriebssystem aber wie hat denn
reiner Brüderle auf den Tisch gehauen
nachdem er gehört hat wir steigen aus
Energie dann doch wieder aus abgekriegt
ich habe ja mich ja dagegen gebannt und
zwar einen Tag vor der zweite Haare vor
der Landtagswahl Baden-Württemberg
Rheinland-Pfalz wo gezielt aus einem
Gespräch mit dem bdi-vorstand berichtet
wurde ich hätte das angeblich gesagt
dass er nur vor dem Ball Gegenteil ist
ich habe gesagt wir müssen das Anpassen
richtig vernünftig einordnen dabei weil
geradezu eine Hysterie natürlich haben
die Grünen gejubelt den Opposition war
und nachdem die großen Parteien die SPD
hatte mit beschlossen mit dem Grün 10
Jahre deine Ausstieg dabei auch das
gemacht haben war das allgemeine breiter
Konsens ich war damals eine Mini
Minderheit der anders gedacht hat dabei
schon mal alle volle raus wunderbar ist
genial wir gehen da möglichst schnell
raus hoch Risikotechnologie die
Kernenergie und wir gehen auf Gas dabei
das umweltfreundlich und ist der bessere
Weg wenn sie jetzt Frau Merkel treffen
würden mit dem was in der Zwischenzeit
passiert ist was würden Sie Ihr dann
sagen hätten sie mal auf mich gehört
oder würden Sie sagen war alles misst
damals auch nicht machen sie waren
damals die großen Parteien die Grünen es
war eine Minderheit die dagegen waren
auf diesen Trip es war auch Herr Röttgen
der Umweltminister der wollte auch
möglichst schnell raus war nicht so Frau
Merkel als Physikern ja mit der Materie
bekannt war ja am Anfang mit uns
gemeinsam für die zehn Jahre
Verlängerung das hat wegen Japan dann
abrupt geändert wo die Politik geändert
ist
man doch Frau Merkel durchaus finde ich
dann kann man sie nicht aus der
Verantwortung lassen sie hat ja damals
nicht aus Einsicht als Physikerin die
Atomkraft verlassen sondern das hat man
hat es wirklich aus wahltaktischen
Gründen getan im Parlament dafür oder
debokardie ist es so wenn Sie mehr dafür
gibt dann findet statt es nicht Frau
Merkel allein oder der Oberregierungsrat
im Ministerium des entscheidet sondern
klare parlamentarische Mehrheiten die
das beschlossen haben das war falsch
aber es gab diese Mehrheit aber da muss
man Demokratie respektieren kann die
Zahlen ich bin sauer ist die
parlamentische Entscheidung als Bürger
als normaler Bürger wen mache ich jetzt
eigentlich haftbar oder als Unternehmer
wen mache ich haftbar wenn man das
Parlament von vor zehn Jahren oder von
15 Jahren kann ich ja schlecht haftbar
machen
ja das ist genau das Problem ich glaube
dass niemand Schuld sein will
Verantwortung übernehmen sondern alle
stehen jetzt irgendwie vor einer Sache
und nicht einmal jetzt in dieser
Situation will man verantwortungsbewusst
handeln oder wenigstens die Fehler
bekennen die passiert sind und sie auch
verändern die Fehler sind ja öffentlich
auch bekannt dabei natürlich werden sie
verändert ist natürlich sehr schwer wir
haben versucht auf die regenerative
Energien zu gehen es sind leider nicht
die Leitung gebaut werden weil die
gleichen die für Ausstieg aus der
Kernenergie Atoms der Kohle waren denn
auch die Leitung nämlich sehr viel von
den Grünen blockiert haben von Dortmund
zum Süden Wind Energie haben wir mehr in
der Nord ein Ostsee als in südregion
dort sind die Industrie es muss
hunderten runter verwendet werden wir
haben keine entsprechende Energieleiter
wir können es gar nicht im Süden runter
schaffen und Baden-Württemberg und
Bayern hat die wenigsten
Windkraftanlagen und Solaranlagen
solarmte bisschen mehr in Bayern gebaut
Baden-Württemberg ganz wenigen
Schwarzwald sehe ich kaum Windräder die
sind an einer Region bei uns in der
Eifel im Pfälzerwald und sonst zwei sie
haben es nicht gemacht und sie haben
sich umgesetzt und es gab durch die
Widerstände in Deutschland brauchen sie
im Schnitt fast 25 Jahre und Baurecht
für ein Stück Straße zu haben das sind
Bürger die dagegen sind die Einsprüche
erheben und das Blockieren deshalb
brauchen wir neue Regelung wo der
schneller geht nicht nur Frau Kelle
findet eigentlich das zu wenig getan
wird auch Herr grob hier in der Straße
ich meine ich finde es ja gut wenn man
sagt Fukushima das hat ja den Bürgern
Angst eingejagt und gewählt Herr
Kretschmer damals
ich habe immer die CDU gewählt werden
und habe dann aber auch
aber ich wollte nur sagen wenn wir diese
Atomausstieg so schnell besprochen
bestätigt haben dann musste habe ich
mich gefragt wenn Frankreich der bei uns
in Baden-Württemberg 20 Kilometer hinter
der Grenze Atomkraftwerk hat und
Fukushima ja nicht nur jetzt im Umkreis
von 5 km oder sonst was dann habe ich
mich gefragt das müsste doch europäisch
gemeinsam gelöst werden und wenn die
Franzosen die größte Atomkraft sind er
macht sind immer mehr aufbaut dann ist
es doch falsch wenn wir abbauen es
müsste doch gemeinsam sein und das und
das habe ich im Prinzip immer gefragt
wir kommen jetzt einmal zur These von
Herr Group von heute was fordern Sie
heute Abend hier bei 8:15 Uhr